- Hi, I'm Zack,
and I'm single as fuck.
I'm 25 years old,
and I've never been in a
long-term committed relationship.
But I think I'm ready, so
I've been trying my best
to get back out there,
or just out there.
I was using OkCupid the other day
and noticed an odd feature.
So I sat down with the site's Co-Founder
and "Dataclysm" author Christian Rudder
to get some answers.
I'm sure you've heard the
idiom, "opposites attract?"
- (laughs) I've heard every
idiom related to attraction
and dating and sex that there is.
- Does OkCupid account for that idea,
that maybe people who
are complete opposites
are the ones that are
attracted to each other?
- We have this enemy percentage,
which is the third of
the three percentages.
It's basically how much we think
you guys would hate each other.
- You can sort by enemy percentage.
So you've made it very easy.
I can search by who I would hate the most.
- Yeah, you can find that person
on OkCupid, thank goodness.
- So I devised a plan,
use OkCupid's enemy filter to
track down my dating nemesis,
ask her on a date,
and settle once and for
all if opposites attract.
So do you think this
experiment's gonna work?
- Uh, probably not.
- Alright, we're gonna
try and find a nemesis.
Let's do it.
Already I'm seeing people
who are 89% enemies
with 0% match.
That's pretty outstanding.
Could you date someone
who is really messy?
I said yes, she said no.
Really, that's why we're enemies?
Do you use foul language?
I said fuck yeah, she said no.
That's an issue.
For now, I'm looking for
someone who won't be afraid
to watch and pay $5 it
takes to play with me
on my naughty cam show.
She wants me to pay to
go on a date with her?
You think it's a bot?
Turns out, finding a high percentage enemy
is harder than I thought.
A lot of the people who are
my highest percentage enemies
either only filled out four questions,
or are porn robots,
which is not what we're here for.
FatFetish88, you know I'm gonna check--
Oh my god!
You guys, I got a message.
Rieanah.
She put little emojis in her profile.
I don't like that.
Do you feel that having sex with someone
you have known less than
one year would be too soon?
No, that's crazy.
She said yes.
Protesting civil rights issues
is super important. (scoffs)
She says (laughs)
protesting for civil rights
is just for pretentious
snobs who want attention.
I found the worst person on OkCupid.
She said:
No no no no no.
I can not lose her.
Hillary, Hillary.
- Yes yes yes yes yes.
- Ok, so I found this woman,
she's awful.
- Listen, all answers are good answers.
Your answers are just different.
- Dude, she's flirting with me.
- Yeah, okay.
- She's flirting with me.
We got one!
We're done here.
- Zack and Rieahna. Let's see.
(laughing)
- So, I'm about to go on
a date with my nemesis
and I'm really excited.
To put it kindly, Rieanah
seems awful. (laughs)
She doesn't seem to
believe in premarital sex.
I've only had premarital sex.
She's against smoking pot.
I'm not.
Even though we're in opposition,
because we're in such opposition,
will that lead to a level of attraction?
I'm excited.
Let's meet her.
30,000 couples will have
their first date tonight
because of OkCupid.
3,000 of them will end long-term together.
That's every day?
Rieanah?
- Hi!
- Hi.
- There's no one perfect match.
There's not even 1,000 perfect matches.
There's tens of thousands
of "perfect matches"
for every person out there.
- Shall we?
- The first time I saw his profile,
I was like, bro, I can't
even with you right now.
- Hopefully we don't kill each other.
- Hopefully not.
Or if you do, you kill
each other at the same time
so there's nobody to prosecute.
- Rieanah, we have a lovely picnic set.
Get some wine going.
- Uh, wine?
Really, bro? Broad daylight?
- You don't like wine?
- I don't like wine at all. (laughs)
- Like not at all?
- Not at all.
- Okay.
When I'm talking to my nemesis,
do you think that the opening,
"Hey, OkCupid says we
should hate each other.
"How's it going?"
- Yeah, no, I think that's really good.
And maybe "fuck you" at
the end of that, too.
- Are you comfortable?
Yeah, get comfortable.
- I'm good.
- On your knees?
That hurts me if I sit like that.
- I'm Asian.
- So, this is how Asians sit?
- Well, this is how I sit.
- What did you think
about my profile pictures?
- Cute.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
So adorable. (laughs)
- Sexy or adorable?
- Adorable.
- Oh.
- Are you down to have
sex on the first date?
Like, you're not gonna say that.
We found that "Do you
like the taste of beer?"
correlates most highly with
"Would you be up for
sex on the first date?"
- So you don't like wine.
Do you like the taste of beer?
No?
Not even a little bit?
I thought it would be interesting
to look at the questions
that we answered differently.
And if you're cool, we
could just talk about 'em.
- Let's do it.
Well, we all know my name is Rieanah.
- Are you named after the pop singer?
- No no no no no no no no no no!
Don't anyone go there!
- You don't get down with RiRi?
Somewhere along the way,
the conversation turned,
and Rieanah and I started
having a really nice time.
Do you not like Backstreet Boys?
- Come on.
I love-- What was that guy's name?
- [Both] Nick.
(laughing)
- Now, I'm gonna do this.
- You look way more comfortable now.
- It was fine.
- You said you like hickeys?
- I guess the thought of it is nice.
- But then everyone
sees you have a hickey.
- That's why you do it under,
where it can be hidden.
- Oh, Rieanah.
Okay, alright. I see.
Say you've started seeing
someone you really like.
How long would it take before sex?
- The thing is, I would have
to be really really really
comfortable with the person.
- You want to make sure that someone's
not just using you for sex,
and you know, and it's not a fun feeling.
Sounds like a lot of the
differences that we have
are kind of just misunderstanding
the way you answered the question.
- That's what I say.
Communication, talking
to someone, conversation,
is the best way to
getting to know a person.
- So, Rieanah, this was really great.
Do you want to move on to
the next portion of the date?
- Let's go!
(slow rock music)
- So that was great!
Rieanah and I had a
totally fun, normal date.
I came in expecting
someone that I would hate.
I thought there was gonna
be a lot of yelling,
but it was a really nice time.
The fact that we were opposites on paper
made me want to get to know her more,
and then as we spoke more,
the focus switched from the
things we have in opposition,
to things that we have in common,
and it turns out we have a lot in common.
- OkCupid said that Zack
and I would have a bad date,
but it wasn't right, it wasn't true.
We had a lot of fun.
- So, do opposites attract?
I don't know, but I had a good date,
and that's all that matters,
so thanks, Rieanah.
- Whoo hoo!
- Yep.
Great.
- Alright.
- Good job.
- [Zack] You ready?
- [Rieanah] Let's do this.
- Okay. zero serving zero.
- Oops! My bad!